ich habe vor einiger zeit ein video
hochgeladen was bei euch mega gut ankam
und dann habe ich nach einer gewissen
zeit das ganze noch einmal gespielt und
jetzt meine damen und herren ist die
zeit gekommen an der ich wieder ein
hallo auch schön dich zu sehen
wir befinden uns hier wieder in der
sesamstraße und zwar meinten einige
zuschauer von mireille lukas spielen mal
wieder sesamstraße dürfen nicht alles
gemacht was man da wirklich machen kann
der abende haus ganz rechts mit der
kuppel und den zahlen ist das kino habe
ich brauche auf kino ist es gerade
montagmorgen 28 wer will da ins kino
gehen
ich würde sagen er gebe erst mal das
gebäude hier vorne und sie das spiel
hier vorne haben wir euch jetzt mal
schon gespielt da ging es irgendwie um
gemüse paare hier unten was haben denn
hier hier unten können wir das habe auch
jetzt schon gespielt was kannst du
eigentlich ich klicke jetzt einfach mal
das pferd an gibt es leckere sachen zum
beispiel war damals so der insider ich
würde sagen ich jetzt noch diese tür zum
beispiel drei bis vier
das sind also drei moment sieben ja
genau die wollen was den fährt ich habe
hunger herz genau wie ich glaube sie
haben doch gerade was gegessen du gerade
ich habe aber jetzt muss er ja was geht
ab bei diesen komischen figuren hier
menschen nicht gesetzlich abstoßen ich
würde sagen wir begeben uns mal wieder
den raum steht ob damit tatsächlich
schon alles gemacht aber wir kriegen
jetzt mal einfach hier auf das zweite
gebäude da waren wir letzte mal auch
schon spiele haus gibt es so viele
spiele das emo gar nicht weiß womit der
anfangs noch elmo das problem in deinem
leben das sie haben wir noch nicht
gespielt und zwar werde ich jetzt
jedermann bild malen
also ich fange mal an so macht das so
dann nehme ich jetzt mal kleineren
pinsel mache jetzt mal so und mache hier
so nicht mit den kleinsten kindern mache
jetzt noch einen mund
mein logo ich habe jetzt noch was gemalt
meine damen und herren und zwar dass
hier was könnte das hier sein ist es
eine totale kapitza oder es ist b
die kontraste pizza die mitte oktober in
den laden kommt
es ist di luca pizza die im oktober in
den laden kommt genauere infos folgen
durch den bürgern deinen kopf wir
befinden uns hier wieder gehen jetzt mal
in dieses gebäude ich weiß nicht ob das
der letztes mal überhaupt schon stand
merkt kuck mal wer da ist ja genau ich
dass du da bist danke wenn ich auch toll
ich klicke jetzt mal einfach auf die
socken hier oben das heißt glaube ich
sortiere spiel und hallo du bist ja nie
hat heute alle seine bunten anziehsachen
gewaschen und das ist das ist klasse er
liebt da kann man schon mal klatschen
aber die sind ja alle völlig unsortiert
ja klar wer das ist doch jetzt auch das
spiel ihr vollidioten jetzt nehme ich
die socken und packe die beispielsweise
hier ein die lust dich da muss es sein
doch irgendwas wir sehen diese
beispielsweise die chinas sieht sehr
ordentlich aus
danke mama bin ich die andere seite hier
ein paket nur hier rein in die sache wer
hat die grüne sockel kann er sich nicht
beiden linken roten großartig die
sortiert korb kommen rote sachen kannst
du dir vielleicht noch mehr darüber
erzählen gut danke das nächste dafür und
das hat ja toll geklappt wie kommt's
noch nicht wie viele punkte annäherten
hast du denn genau so gut sortiert
richtig dass die du bringst er richtig
ordnung in dieser 3 vision spätere kommt
noch ich habe schon eine socken die luft
eine hose und ein t shirt sortiert was
willst mit den reds doch gäbe nochmal so
kinder klar wenn du auf den fernseher
kriegst das muss die stadt aber ich bin
all oder freundesclique jetzt mal
einfach auf die auf das entchen hier
vorne in den wasserbehälter hat und ich
wollen heute experimente machen mal
sehen was schwimmt und was untergeht
ich muss mir jetzt hingegen stand
aussuchen wo wir dann schauen ob der auf
dem wasser schwimmt oder ob der
unterricht und sagen den hammer weil ich
bin aber was macht der hammer wenn er im
wasser land ene mene miste es rappelt in
der kiste ene mene meck und du bist weg
also wir sagen der hammer geht
tatsächlich unter und wir schauen jetzt
mal was das nicht sogar gesagt ich gehe
jetzt mal hier rechts auf kino und park
und jetzt haben wir hier
hallo schön dass du nie der sesamstraße
besucht
da bin ich jetzt schon den ganzen tag
letztes mal waren wir schon im park das
heißt ich werde jetzt mal hier in das
schneckenhaus gene bei so viel arbeit
kommt eine schnecke wie ich manchmal
ganz schön außer puste gekommen beide
pakete in iran wo brauchst du denn hilfe
meine sehr verehrten schnecke zu den
bewohnern der sesamstraße einen brief
schicken
yao klick auf die stempel ich wollte
doch nie was anderes werden in meinem
leben ich würde jetzt allerdings sagen
meine damen und herren bevor ich den
brief ab schicke und der strecke noch
nachher weiterhelfe und ich danach
werden wir noch ins kino und vielleicht
noch mal den park zu wert gehen werde
werde ich jetzt dieses video an der
stelle erst mal beenden und schauen clip
die marke drauf ich habe doch gar keine
marke draufgeklebt wenn euch dieses
video hier gefallen hat aus der
sesamstraße dann will ich mich sehr über
einen daumen hoch von euch freund
schreibt man in die kommentare
sesamstraße wenn ihr wollt dass ich das
irgendwie in ein paar tagen noch mal
hoch laden und das dann hier weiter
spielen an der stelle und sonst würde
ich jetzt sagen meine damen und herren
rollen wir jetzt etwas rein
das was jetzt hier vom video hier können
jetzt jemand einen kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten meinen job hier findet ihr
zwei andere videos und menschen
seid könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]